ZDF heute live euch allen ein herzliches
Willkommen ja das war heute Vormittag
ein Vormittag mit Ausrufezeichen kann
man sagen im politischen Berlin als
Sarah Wagenknecht ihr neues politisches
Projekt vorgestellt hat ein Verein mit
dem Titel Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht der
Anfang des nächsten Jahres eine neue
Partei gründen soll neben Sagara
Wagenknecht saßen da heute dann auch der
Vereinsvorstand der neue auf dem Podium
der Pressekonferenz und das waren
sozusagen ihre Gefolgsleute und auch ähm
ehemalige Köpfe der Linkspartei und
ehemalig deshalb weil ja dieser Vorstand
der bis dato der Linkspartei angehörte
zusammen mit Sarah Wagenknecht laut
Aussagen heute Vormittag aus der
Linkspartei ausgetreten sind es war also
eine Pressekonferenz mit vielen klaren
Aussagen auf die wir heute bei uns in
der Sendung blicken wollen und natürlich
auch die fragen uns stellen wie
gefährlich kann dann im politischen
Berlin so ein
neues Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht werden
oder wie erfolgreich auch dazu wollen
wir heute sprechen mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole
diegmann und dann auch gleich mit dem
Wahl und Parteienforscher Thorsten Fass
und wie immer hier bei ZDF heute live
seid ihr eingeladen uns Eure Kommentare
eure Fragen zu schicken die wir gerne
auch an unsere Expertinnen und Experten
hier in der Sendung weiterreichen gerne
wie immer über die
kommentarpalten oder via Mail an
zfheute-li@zdf de bevor wir aber
loslegen mit den Gesprächen wollen wir
noch mal auf das schauen was heute
Vormittag da in Berlin genau passiert
ist Nicole digmann hat für uns die
Pressekonferenz mit
begegleitet zwei Jahre lang war
spekuliert worden ob Sarah Wagenknecht
eine Partei gründet nach Gründung eines
Vereins Anfang Oktober hatten sich die
Gerüchte verdichtet entsprechend riesig
das Medienaufgebot heute Morgen an dem
nun die offizielle Bestätigung zu hören
war dieser Verein hat das Ziel eine neue
Partei auf den den Weg zu bringen und
sie alle haben das der Presse richtig
entnommen dass die Entscheidung dafür
jetzt gefallen ist Wagenknecht und neun
ihrer Mitstreiter haben die Partei DIE
LINKE nun verlassen diese drohe in der
politischen Bedeutungslosigkeit zu
versinken und auch die anderen Parteien
seinen für viele nicht mehr wellbar
ausgerechnet in dieser Zeit hat die
Bundesrepublik die wohl schlechteste
Regierung ihrer Geschichte eine
Regierung die planlos kurzsichtig und in
Teilen schlicht inkompetent auftritt und
handelt nun also steht der Verein und
auch der Zeitplan für die Partei unser
Verein trifft jetzt die Vorbereitung für
eine Parteigründung im Januar
2024 wir werden als neue Partei zu
Jahresbeginn erste Strukturen aufstellen
und in der ersten Jahreshälfte werden
wir erste Landesverbände gründen und wir
werden eine starke wahlkampfdurchführung
für das Jahr
2024 sicherstellen zur Europawahl im
kommenden Juni will man erstmals
antreten nun hofft man auf Spenden sehen
ja soweit die Eindrücke von heute
Vormittag von der Pressekonferenz von
Nicole diegmann und mit ihr wollen wir
jetzt reden aus dem ZDF Hauptstadtstudio
ist sie mir zugeschaltet Nicole ich
grüße dich hallo hi hallo zunächst mal
der Vorstand hat ja heute ganz klar
seine Unzufriedenheit ausgedrückt mit
der politischen Situation und auch mit
der Linkspartei und gerade Sarah
Wagenknecht gehörte ihr ja über 30 Jahre
lang an wie kam es denn jetzt zu dem
Entschluss dass man gesagt hat wir
gründen jetzt ein Verein der das Ziel
hat eine eigene neue Partei zu gründen
da wurden heute zwei Wegmarken quasi
zwei Anlässe genannt das sind natürlich
bloße Daten jenseits aller Inhalte das
eine ist die letzte Europawahl 2024 ist
die nächste also war die vor 4er Jahren
2019 seitdem sei man in fast
allen Wahlen unterlegen habe in fast
allen Wahlen verloren sagte man heute
und nun gerade in Hessen wir wisst wir
erinnern uns die die Landtagswahl ist
noch nicht lange her nun sei man mit
Hessen aus dem letzten Flächenland im
Westen geflogen das heißt umgedreht man
sieht überhaupt keine politische Zukunft
mehr für die Linkspartei man werde
höchstwahrscheinlich auch bzw die
Linkspartei werde in zwei Jahren bei der
dann anstehenden bundestagswe vermutlich
rausfliegen aus dem Bundestag und
deswegen sei es nun an der Zeit bevor
die Linke in der politischen
Bedeutungslosigkeit ohnehin versinke
eine neue Partei zu gründen jetzt
schmückt sich der Titel mit den
Schlagworten Vernunft und Gerechtigkeit
worauf will man denn da politisch
fachpolitisch genau setzen mit welchen
Inhalten Punkten wir fangen mal hinten
an bei der Gerechtigkeit dieem man sich
für für sich proklamiert ähm soziale
Gerechtigkeit ist ein großes Thema das
Sarah Wagenknecht heute in den
Mittelpunkt ihrer Pressekonferenz
gerückt hat da geht es unter anderem um
Renten da geht es aber auch um den
Mindestlohn die Linke ist ja auch mal
als großes sozialpolitisches Projekt
angetreten und zumindest laut Auffassung
derer die sich da heute präsentiert
haben die nun ein gegenprojekt Z linken
gründen wollen hält die Linke dieses
Versprechen nicht mehr unter Vernunft
fällt unter das Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht
so heißt es ja im Moment die Partei soll
dann einen anderen Namen tragen darunter
fallen so Schlagworte die heute zu hören
waren wie z.B zurück zu Gas und
Öllieferungen aus Russland ein
wahnsinnig Heikes Thema und das andere
Thema das unter Vernunft Feld ist die
sogenannte
Energiewende da spricht Sarah
Wagenknecht von einem Irrweg das könne
man so nicht machen wie es im Moment
liefe und dritter großer Punkt die
Migrationspolitik Sarah Wagenknecht
spricht sich gegen eine wie sie es nennt
unregulierte Migrationspolitik
Zuwanderung aus mm nun wurde die oder
ist die neue Partei ja noch nicht
gegründet worden das wurde ja heute
erstmal der neue Verein vorgestellt und
doch sind dadurch schon erste Wellen in
Gang dan gesetzt natürlich seit dem
Wochenende gerade innerhalb der
Linkspartei welche Probleme haben sich
denn da jetzt aufgetan für die
Linkspartei im Bundestag viele und zum
Teil massive also ganz praktisch gesehen
ist es nun so dass diese Zeh die sich da
heute morgen zu erkennen gegeben haben
aus der
Linkspartei ausgetreten sind neun von
ihnen gehören aus der auch der
Linksfraktion im Bundestag an es ist
klar dass wenn man dann eine neue Partei
gegründet hat man schlecht für eine
andere Partei weiterhin in der Fraktion
sitzen kann die Parteigründung ist ja
wir haben das eben gehört für den Januar
anberaumt bis dahin so wollen es
zumindest Wagenknecht und ihre
Mitstreiter wollen sie in der
Linksfraktion bleiben das ist ein etwas
absurder Vorgang Leute in der eigenen
Fraktion sitzen zu haben die öffentlich
erklärt haben wie mies die eigene
Parteiarbeit eigentlich ist wie schlecht
diese Partei ist dass sie einem keinen
anderen auswig mehr lässt als eine
andere Partei zu gründen auf der and
anderen Seite aber und so begründen
Wagenknecht und andere ihren Verbleib
bis eben zur Parteigründung in der
Linksfraktion es gibt viele
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter es sind
wohl 108 die für
Fraktionsmitglieder der Linken Arbeiten
sobald auch nur zwei Leute die jetzige
Linksfraktion verlassen verliert die
Linke ihren Fraktionsstatus das bedeutet
dass Sie auch unter anderem weniger
Gelder für Personal bekommt das heißt
diese 10 Leute die da arbeiten können
nicht mehr finanziert werden und nun
sagen Wagenknecht und andere wir bleiben
bis Januar eben auch weil sie dann ja
ihre Partei gründen wollen aber das
ermöglicht diesen 108 Leuten und ihren
Familien bzw denen die dann gehen müssen
von diesen 108 Leuten einen womöglich
geordneten Übergang die stehen nicht von
heute auf morgen vor den Scherben ihrer
Existenz das ist das eine das ist ein
Thema das andere Thema ist dass die
Links Fraktion ich habe es eben schon
gesagt sobald auch nur zwei Leute und es
sieht ja nach viel mehr aus diese
Fraktion verlassen keine Fraktion mehr
ist sie kann dann eine Gruppe gründen
sie stellt dann eine Gruppe im Bundestag
da hat aber z.B in Ausschüssen weniger
Rechte kann auch keine kleinen oder
großen Anfragen mehr stellen unsere
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer die
spekulieren schon fleißig nach den
Erfolgsaussichten dieses möglichen
Bündnisses und da fällt auch das
Stichwort AFD
die neue Partei könnte ihr ja
tatsächlich gefährlich werden sollte es
zu einer erfolgreichen Gründung kommen
wenn man sich die Pressekonferenz Nicole
heute auch angehört hat zielt
Wagenknecht da ja auch schon drauf ab
sie hatte da heute Stellung zu bezogen
wir können mal kurz reinhören was sie
dazu gesagt hat also selbstverständlich
werden wir nicht gemeinsame Sachen mit
der AFD machen ich meine wir bringen
eine Partei an den Staat damit all die
Menschen die auch als Wut aus
Verzweiflung aber eben nicht weil sie
recht sind jetzt darüber nachdenken AFD
zu wählen oder das auch schon gemacht
haben damit diese Menschen eine seriöse
Adresse
haben ja viele wandern vielleicht rüber
schreibt rinax von der AFD was meinst Du
dann das Kang ja schon so ein bisschen
nach Angriff heute von Wagenknecht
gegenüber der AFD wie gefährlich könnte
dann eine neue Sarah Wagenknecht Partei
der AFD werden es gibt Zahlen es gibt
aus der vergangenen Woche eine
forsaumfrage 20 Oktober müsste das
gewesen sein also noch sehr frisch
wonach 40% der AFD Wähler sich derzeit
vorstellen könnten dann einer wie auch
immer sie dann heißt Partei von Sarah
Wagenknecht beizutreten bzw sie zu
wählen und ähm 32% der ostdeutschen und
das ist ja Ost das ist ja AFD
Territorium derzeit 32% der ostdeutschen
könnten sich ebenfalls vorstellen Sara
wagenknechts Partei zu wählen das ich
will das dazu sagen natürlich ist das
was Sarah Wagenknecht gerade gesagt hat
ein Frontalangriff auf die AFD natürlich
will sie egal wo möglichst viele
wellerinnen und Weller abjagen sonst
müsste man sich ja nicht zur Wahl
stellen auf der anderen Seite
ähm hat Sarah wagenknechter heute auch
aus einer gewissen Defensive heraus
geantwortet denn sie hatte sich in den
vergangenen Monaten als dieses Thema
Parteigründung ja hier schon durch
politische Berlin wabberte immer ein
bisschen Versuch zurückzuhalten mit
Aussagen wie steht sie zur AFD und das
heute morgen war dann tatsächlich auf
die klare Nachfrage wie sie es denn eben
hält mit der in Thailand ja
rechtsextremen Partei ja und ähm es gibt
pro und kontra auch bei unseren Usern
das ist gerade ganz spannend auch zu
sehen benura schreibt das wird ein Flop
ähm corvide schreibt wenn sie keine
anderen Zugpferde gewinnt aus der
Linkspartei wird das nichts aber es gibt
auch Befürworter die Ikone des
Widerstands darer Wagenknecht ein Hoch
auf die nächste Kanzlerin schreibt sogar
Hans Weber oder redchirt schreibt
hauptsache mal eine Partei mit Vision
für die Zukunft und keine 16 Jahre gar
nichts CDU oder die chaosampel also doch
schon auch eine gute Debatte bei uns
gerade in den Foren ihr könnt uns weiter
in eure Kommentare und auch Fragen
schicken Nicole danke schön für den
Moment wir reden gleich weiter auch über
mögliche Chancen oder auch nicht für die
eine neue Sarah Wagenknecht Partei wir
wollen zunächst aber mal darauf schauen
welche Turbulenzen die neue Partei
auslösen könnte im politischen Berlin
und dazu begrüße ich nun den Wahl und
Parteienforscher Torsten FAS ein schön
guten Tag zu Ihnen Herr FS grüße sie
hallo Herr F was glauben Sie sie haben
ja sicherlich heute auch verfolgt am
Vormittag wie groß könnte so ein
politisches Erdbeben werden sollte im
Januar das glücken mit der neuen Partei
ja das ist schon ein historischer Tag
heute könnte man sagen weil wir zum
ersten Mal erleben dass wirklich eine
Partei mit nationalem Anspruch also
bundesweit agieren zu wollen rund um
eine Person antritt das kennen wir so
nicht und mit Sarah wagenkncht steht
eine Person an der Spitze dieser noch
Verein bald Partei die sehr sehr bekannt
ist die auch in Teil in der Gesellschaft
sehr positiv gesehen wird also das ist
sicherlich kein Projekt was von Anfang
an zum Scheitern verurteilt ist und
entsprechend groß ist glaube ich die
Nervosität was folgt jetzt daraus wie
wird sich das Ganze entwickeln aber ein
Potenzial ist sicherlich da das haben
wir ja gerade auch von Nicole digmann
schon gehört ja und glaubt man den
Worten Sara Wagenknecht soll fachpolitik
im Fokus stehen worauf man setzen will
nicole digmann hat gerade schon
angesprochen Sozialpolitik steht im
Mittelpunkt Asylpolitik wir sie
thematisieren aber auch Kriege und
Krisen da hat sie sich heute in der
Konferenz auch zu geäußert da können wir
mal ganz kurz
reinhören aber die Konflikte lassen sich
militärisch nicht lösen das gilt für die
Ukraine und das gilt für den Nahen Osten
und es gilt für viele andere Teile
dieser Welt und wir sind überzeugt es
braucht eine starke politische Kraft die
konsequent für Frieden Diplomatie und
Verhandlungslösungen wirbt und die die
Vorstellung Kriege ließen sich durch
noch mehr Waffen beenden eindeutig und
deutlich abl
ablehnt da sind schon einige typische
politische Floskel mit dabei die man
auch von anderen Parteien hört Herr FS m
spricht Wagenknecht trotzd Menschen an
könnte sie potentiell viele neue Wähler
gewinnen mit ihren Themen die sie da
setzt ja das war ja heute auch eine
Vorstellung vor der Hauptstadtpresse und
da war es natürlich auch wichtig sofort
den Eindruck zu zerstreuen man hätte da
inhaltlich nichts anzubieten aber
gegenüber der Bevölkerung auch das ist
glaube ich heute schon sehr sehr
deutlich geworden gegenüber Wählerinnen
und Wählern da geht es vor allem darum
Unzufriedenheit in neue nämlich die
eigenen Bahnen zu lenken und die
Schlagworte die wir gehört haben
Vernunft Gerechtigkeit Frieden Freiheit
da ist natürlich letztlich niemand
dagegen wenn man das so formuliert aber
zugleich gibt es durchaus Tendenzen
Bevölkerungsgruppen in diesem Land die
eben bisher das Gefühl haben es wird
nicht genug sich eingesetzt für eine
friedliche Lösung oder die eben auch das
Gefühl haben es geht sehr ungerecht zu
in diesem Land man darf nicht mehr sagen
was man sagen möchte und das ganze hat
irgendwie die Vernunft verlor ich glaube
genau dieses Lebensgefühl diese
Unzufriedenheit die es offenkundig in
der Bevölkerung gibt die hat Sarah
Wagenknecht mit ihrem Projekt in den
Blick genommen und das ist dann auch
genau das wo es für die AFD gefährlich
wird weil das ist bisher ein terrin wo
die AFD sehr sehr stark mit Punkten
konnte jetzt haben wir hier ein zweites
Angebot also insofern durchaus spannend
was wir da auch an Wettbewerb um rund um
die Unzufriedenheit in Zukunft sehen
werden das knüpft jetzt sehr gut an an
die Frage unseres Zuschauers Linus was
ges sag hab F er fragt warum kommt
Wagenknecht gerade bei AFD wan gut an
steht sie politisch er rechts als
links ja da wäre ich ein bisschen
vorsichtig weil es ist natürlich ein
klar linkes Projekt und wenn man auch
immer gesagt hat sie steht selbst
innerhalb der Linkspartei für ein linkes
Profil dann merkt man da auch schon das
ist sicherlich keine Politikerin die die
eine rechte Position vertritt aber wenn
wir auf die andere Seite schauen wenn
wir auf die AFD schauen dann sehen wir
dort eigentlich immer so zwei Gruppen
von W in und Wähler nämlich diejenigen
die wirklich hart Rechte zum Teil
rechtsextreme Einstellungen haben um die
geht es Sarah Wagenknecht glaube ich
weniger aber diese zweite Gruppe die die
AFD vor allem aus dem Motiv großer
großer Unzufriedenheit und auch so ein
Gefühl heraus dass man einfach nicht
mehr gehört wird als normaler Mensch wie
es dann immer heißt das ist eine Gruppe
die Sarah Wagenknecht auch mit der
heutigen Pressekonferenz ganz gezielt
anspricht ganz gezielt in den Blick
nimmt und noch mal das ist bisher ein
starkes Potenzial und auch ein starkes
Reservoir für die AFD dass der Partei
der AFD zukünftig nicht mehr automatisch
zuneigen
wird mit der AFD geht ja auch das
Stichwort Verfassungsschutz einher ein
Zuschauer fragt zum Thema
Verfassungsschutz und Wagenknecht muss
dann der Verfassungsschutz jetzt da auch
genauer hinsehen bezüglich wagenknechts
Russland
Nähe da wäre ich ein wenig zurückhaltend
der Verfassungsschutz beobachtet die AFD
ja vor allem wegen extremistischer
Einstellung wo es um Menschenrechte etc
geht das auf Russland zu übertragen das
ist schon ein weiter Weg und da kann man
sicherlich sehr geteilter Meinung sein
was Russland betrifft was
Waffenlieferung betrifft ich glaube
nicht dass wir hier davon sprechen dass
das potenziell verfassungswidrig ist
sondern das sind Positionen die
vielleicht in der Minderheit sind die
man auch sehr sehr kritisch sehen kann
aber die nicht automatisch mit dem
Grundgesetz mit der Verfassung nicht
Verein sind insofern wäre ich da etwas
zurückhalten oder eher zurückweisend
sogar was diese Position betrifft auch
die Linke ist in ihrer Geschichte oder
die PDS früher ja durchaus beobachtet
worden aber das ist doch eine andere
Dimension als wir es mit unter bei der
AFD heute sehen mhm nun haben es die
letzten bundestags- und Landtagswahlen
gezeigt dass es immer schwieriger wird
Koalitionen zu bilden und zu finden die
sich dann auch über mehrere Jahre
vertragen äh mit einer weiteren Partei
nun die eventuell dazu kommt das wird
doch dann eigentlich noch
schwieriger ja das hängt so ein bisschen
davon ab wo diese neue Partei
tatsächlich Erfolge verzeichnet oder
welche Wählergruppen sie tatsächlich
anzieht wenn man sich vorstellt dass es
vor allem bisherige wählerinen und
Wähler der AFD sind dann bleibt es
weiterhin schwierig bei den Parteien in
der Mitte könnte man sagen Mehrheiten zu
finden aber es wird zumindest nicht
zusätzlich schwieriger weil sich einfach
sozusagen die Prozente an den Rändern
neu verteilen wenn es aber den bsw
Projekt gelingt auch aus der Mitte
heraus weitere Unzufriedenheit aus der
Ampel vielleicht auch mit der Union in
ihre Richtung zu lenken na dann wird es
eben für die Parteien die typischerweise
Regierung bilden sPD FDP grüne CDU CSU
eben tatsächlich noch schwerer diese
Mehrheiten zu bilden und insofern hängt
es tatsächlich ein wenig davon ab wo die
Partei zukünftig Punkten wird es heißt
aber nicht automatisch dass es
schwieriger werden wird also insofern
sollte man da auch ein realistischen
Blick darauf haben und jetzt nicht
gleich erwarten dass alles nur noch viel
schlimmer und dann irgendwann auch
unmöglich werden wird sagt der Wahl und
Parteienforscher Torsten FAS Herr FAS
ganz lieben Dank für Ihre Zeit danke für
das Gespräch sehr sehr gerne ja und
damit wollen wir noch mal zurückschalten
ins ZDF Hauptstadtstudio wo unsere
Kollegin Nicole digmann sitzt Nicole wir
haben es besprochen die ersten Wellen
sind in Gang gesetzt sind ausgelöst und
das schon seit dem Wochenende auch
innerhalb der Linkspartei Martin
schirdewann der hat bereits Konsequenzen
angedroht gehabt am Wochenende der
kovorsitzende und
meinte dann wollle man die anderen
ausschließen die sich jetzt Wagenknecht
dort anschließen wollen wir können da in
den oton noch mal kurz reinhören ich
will zunächst klarstellen dass wir diese
Abgeordneten auffordern ihre durch die
Linke errungene Mandate niederzulegen es
handelt sich um mit den Worten unserer
drei direkt gewählten
Bundestagsabgeordneten zu sprechen also
Gregor Gesi Gesine Lösch und Sören
Pellmann um einen höchst unmoralischen
Diebstahl sollten diese Mandate nicht
zurückgegeben werden auch die drei
direkt gewählten fordern die aus der
linken ausgetretenen Abgeordneten auf
ihre Mandate niederzulegen das würde im
übrigen auch die Existenz der Fraktion
sichern jetzt hat der Vorstand
angekündigt heute morgen dass sie
ausgetreten sind aus der Linkspartei
somit diese Androhung des Rauswurfs vom
Wochenende ist ja nun eigentlich obsolet
kann man eigentlich bilanzieren Nicole
dass die Linkspartei jetzt der große
Verlierer von dieser ganzen Aktion
ist also das kann man so oder so sehen
diese zehn sind ja aus der Partei
ausgetreten und neun werden
höchstwahrscheinlich im Januar austreten
die Linke kann jetzt schlecht würde als
sozialpolitisches Projekt das ja sein
möchte
schlecht dastehen würde die
Linksfraktion jetzt sagen dann verlasst
bitte auch sofort die Fraktion ich habe
das ja ja gerade schon dargelegt in dem
Moment gibt es keine Fraktion mehr in
dem Moment besteht nur noch eine Gruppe
und in dem Moment müssen viele
Mitarbeiter von jetzt auf gleich um ihre
Arbeitsplätze bangen die eben für links
Abgeordnete ähm arbeiten das ist das
eine das andere ist aber gehen wir mal
einen Schritt weiter tun wir mal so als
wäre das jetzt passiert schon ähm
Wagenknecht und ihre Mitstreiter
vielleicht noch ein paar mehr wir wissen
es nicht hätten die Linksfraktion
verlassen diese ist keine Fraktion mehr
und ist nun eine Gruppe innerhalb des
Bundestags dann und das ist die Hoffnung
vielleicht ein Stück weit eine
demonstrative Hoffnung was bleibt ihnen
auch anderes übrig so sagen einige
Linkspolitiker jetzt in dem Moment kehrt
aber Frieden ein dann ist endlich
Schluss mit diesen jahrelangen
streitereinen die wir mit Sarah
Wagenknecht hatten wir erinnern uns es
läuft ja auch ein
Parteiausschlussverfahren gegen Sarah
Wagenknecht wobei das jetzt obsolit ist
sie ist ja nicht mehr Parteimitglied
aber Sarah Wagenknecht ist für die
Linkspartei Fluch und Segen zugleich
gewesen sie ist eine Ikone unbestritten
und war das prominenteste Gesicht dieser
Partei mit einer enormen Zugwirkung ja
sie war Spitzenkandidatin auch in NRW
für die Bundestagswahl gleichzeitig aber
hat sie diese Partei gespalten mit
diesem Projekt dass sie nun heute
tatsächlich als W angekündigt hat und
das schon so lange zwei Jahre lang durch
die Republik wabberte ihre eigene Partei
zu gründen also die Hoffnung der Linken
ist
jetzt wenn Sarah Wagenknecht und ihre
gefolgschaftt die Partei die Fraktion
endgültig verlassen kehrt Ruhe ein der
Markenkern der Linken kann wieder klar
herausgestellt werden weil es diese
inhaltlichen
grundlegenden Streitigkeiten nicht mehr
gibtm unsere User interessieren sich vor
allem natürlich über mögliche Inhalte
und Positionen die die neue mögliche
Partei da vertreten wird der Zuschauer
jafowo fragt wie sieht es mit den
Inhalten aus wofür steht die Partei
inhaltlich und wo zwischen welchen
Parteien würde man sie einordnen kann
man das schon nach dieser ersten
Pressekonferenz heute irgendwie grob
anreißen dieses Thema Nicole nee das
finde ich total schwierig das kann man
nämlich z.B auch beim Thema Migration
daran kann man das ganz gut festmachen
da ist im Moment so viel in Bewegung wir
sehen den aktuellen spiegeltitel mit
Kanzler Scholz der sich zum Thema
Abschiebungen äußert wir sehen die
gerade innerhalb der EU sich in Dynamik
befindenden neuen Regelungen zum Thema
Migration Einwanderung Fluch
da bewegt sich gerade sowieso ganz viel
deswegen ist es jetzt wirklich schwer zu
sagen allein in diesem Punkt wo steht
diese neue noch zu gründende Partei wir
haben das ja vorhin schon einmal
gesagt es ist jetzt auch im Moment ja
noch gar nichts es gibt noch kein
Parteiprogramm wie auch es gibt ja noch
nicht mal eine Partei da wurden heute
morgen ein paar inhaltliche flöcke
eingeschlagen Mindestlohn zu niedrig
Renten zu niedrig Migration habe ich
gerade schon genannt irreguläre
Migration beschränken Einwanderung
beschränken das sind Punkte ähm
Friedensverhandlungen zwischen Ukraine
und Russland was ja völlig utopisch ist
aber das ist eine das sind Forderungen
die da heute morgen erhoben worden sind
genauso wie das Ende der Sanktion gegen
Russland ähm das wird sich alles noch
zurecht ruckeln das muss man dann mal in
ein Programm schreiben
und noch mal diese Partei ist noch nicht
gegründet es ist noch gar nicht klar wer
gehört denn dieser Partei an wer sitzt
denn im Partei Vorstand diese Leute
müssen untereinander ja auch noch mal
ihre Themen miteinander so auf einen
gemeinsamen Nenner bringen dass man die
eben in ein Parteiprogramm meißeln kann
das sind noch sehr viele und sehr
grundlegende und sehr offene Fragen ja
deswegen ist das alles jetzt erst mal
auch spekulativ das meiste was wir hier
heute besprechen und doch Nicole zum
Abschluss die Frage was glaubst Du
werden sich dann noch weitere
Abgeordnete der Linkspartei im kommenden
Jahr sofern es die Partei dann die neue
Partei um unsarer wagenkncht geben
sollte anschließen würden das ist eine
gute Frage und ich würde sagen das wird
sich im Laufe der Zeit wahrscheinlich
ergeben denn
wer jetzt ein festes Mandat im Bundestag
hat muss das ohne Not ja erstmal nicht
aufgeben vor allem ein Projekt von dem
man nicht weiß ob und wie erfolgreich es
überhaupt sein wird Sara Wagenknecht hat
schon mal mit Aufstehen so hieß es
damals
ein Projekt gestartet und ist damit
krachend gescheitert es ist über Haupt
nicht gesichert dass diese Partei
wirklich genug Spenden die sie jetzt
braucht genug Mitstreiter genug Kraft
und ganz wichtig genug wa sammelt um
wirklich so durchzustarten wie man das
gerne möchte und davon wird für ganz
viele auch jetzige linke oder für einige
jetzige linken Abgeordnete sicherlich
auch abhängig sein abgesehen von ihrer
inneren Überzeugung ob Sie die Seite
wechseln oder nicht tja also es bleiben
noch etliche Hörden ihr im ZF
Hauptstadtstudio werdet alles für uns
verfolgen und bestimmt treffen wir uns
dann hier noch mal wieder Nicole und
reden weiter wenn es konkrete Pläne oder
Neuigkeiten dazu gibt liebe Grüße ins
Hauptstadtstudio nicole digmann war das
Nicole ich wünsche dir einen schönen
Nachmittag danke danke gleichfalls liebe
Grüße zurück ja und danke auch an euch
für die vielen Kommentare und Anregungen
ihr diskutiert fleißig weiter sehen wir
hier pro und kontra gibt's zu diesem
Thema also wir bei ZDF heute live werden
dieses Thema auf alle Fälle weiterhin
verfolgen danken euch erstmal fürs
Interesse fürs einschalten und sagen
tschüss bis zum nächsten
Mal